bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à strasbourg pour une nouvelle
saison d'actualité européenne break site
crise des réfugiés politiques
migratoires détachement des travailleurs
taffetas le fameux traité
transatlantique les enjeux de ces
prochains mois sont légion et il ya
quelques mois des élections générales en
allemagne et de la présidentielle en
france
inutile de dire que l'europe sera au
centre des débats alors pour ouvrir en
fanfare cette nouvelle saison europe
hebdo nouvelle mouture reçoit martin
schulz le président du parlement
européen et du coup on a fait le tour de
la question à commencer par l'avenir de
l'europe
rien que ça c'était au menu du sommet de
bratislava il y a quelques jours et sans
surprise il n'en est pas sorti grand
chose
un calendrier après une journée de
sommet inédit à 27 à bratislava sans la
grande bretagne les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement se sont mis d'accord sur un
calendrier un bilan bien maigre pour
faire face à la situation critique de
l'union pas de break si nous voulons
tous montrer notre unité et nous voulons
tous montré que c'est l'unique projet et
que nous devons mener à bien ce projet
les attentes sont grandes
concernant le résultat final mais le
processus va prendre six mois si les
européens ont tenté de montrer un visage
uni à l'image de la parfaite photo de
famille du sommet il n'en est rien à
quelques mois d'échéances électorales
décisives notamment en france et en
allemagne
l'idée est avant tout de démontrer que
les défis sont relevés soir c'est la
dislocation soit c'est la déduction
soit c'est au contraire la volonté
commune de donner un projet à l'europe
ce que j'appelle la nouvelle impulsion
nous sommes dans une situation critique
nous devons montrer par nos actions que
nous pouvons mieux faire des mesures
concrètes qui se font désespérément
attendre et ce malgré les annonces du
président de la commission européenne
jean claude juncker lors de son discours
sur l'état de l'union
respectons la décision britannique tout
en la déplorant mais l'union européenne
n'est pas menacé dans son existence par
cette décision il faut que la demande de
sortie du royaume uni nous parviennent
rapidement pour mettre un terme aux
rumeurs et incertitudes en réponse
theresa may premier ministre britannique
a assuré que le déclenchement de
l'article 50 aurait lieu avant fin mars
nos lois seront en fait non pas à
bruxelles mais west mister jo reyes
georges les juges qui interpréteront ces
lois seront non pas au luxembourg mais
dans les tribunaux de ce pays
c'est la fin de l'autorité de l'union
européenne sur le royaume uni
s'ouvrira alors une période de deux ans
de négociations qui risque de faire
vaciller l'europe
une fois de plus
bonjour martine jolit merci de nous
recevoir ici au 15e étage dans votre
bureau
theresa may annonce qu elle activera
l'article 50 avant la fin mars 2017
est ce que vous êtes soulagé de cette
décision de cette annonce à ce que c'est
encore trop tard soulagés certainement
exagéré finalement en a bien entendu sur
le congrès d'un parti par au siège du
premier ministre l'annnonce de la date
ça c'est déjà une faute non ça c'est
remarquable que toute l'europe doit
attendre depuis des mois et des mois
rappelle rappelle arnoud leveaux d'été
au mois de juin
le 23 joueurs et toute l'europe doit
d'attendre jusqu'au congrès du parti
conservateur jusqu'à déco intérieure
britannique sont si généreux de nous
dira peut-être fin mars
on va activer latif 50 ça c'est quand
même pas un soulagement c'est tout
d'abord qui surprise que c'est un lieu
sûr un congrès de dames partie 2
finalement on connaît la tendance les
négociations s'annoncent difficiles
est ce que vous vous attendez à ce
qu'ils se soient un petit peu dans la
douleur et qu'on accouche finalement de
quelque chose qui sera plutôt à
l'avantagé des britanniques pour éviter
une concurrence entre les uk entre la
grande bretagne et l'union européenne
notamment sur les questions économiques
c'est très difficile à prévoir comment
les négociations ont lieu que sont les
priorités des deux côtés une chose est
claire sont notification pas de
négociations donc moi je reste très
strictes tout d'abord nous attendons la
demande du gouvernement du royaume uni
de sortir de l'union européenne sur la
base de l'article 50 à partir de ce
moment on peut discuter
tout d'abord procéduralement ensuite
après on connaît la procédure sur le
contenu donc je m'excuse mais très trop
tôt
pour répondre à votre question bon alors
on reprendra dette à partir de
l'activation de l'article 50 pendant ce
temps là les européens se sont réunis à
bratislava
mi-septembre pour essayer de réfléchir à
l'avenir de l'europe après le break site
ils ont finalement réussi à accoucher
d'un calendrier ce que c'est pas
décevant martin schulz de voir que à 27
on n'est pas capable de réfléchir à
autre chose qu'un calendrier non
quelqu'un qui travaille comme moi dans
la politique européenne doit pas être
déçu parce que là hétérogénéité des
intérêts parmi les vingt huit
actuellement et en futur devant cet
énorme ce qui manque et la volonté pour
le compromis
ça c'était toujours la tour de l'europe
la capacité de faire un compromis ce que
nous voyons ce que les plus radicaux
croire qu'il peut gagner toujours par se
radicaliser chaque jour un peu plus et
ça c'est une erreur et ça c'était
heureusement pas si grave comme avant à
bratislava dedans au contraire de
beaucoup qui ont considéré bratislava
comme soit un échec ou disons un bloc
cage moi j'ai vu à bratislava quand même
la tendance de la volonté sur de
discuter oui mais on a quand même
accouché de pas grand chose hormis des
déclarations d'intention et on l'a
entendu il faut une nouvelle impulsion
il faut essayer la situation est
critique
enfin on est quand même face à des
enjeux qui n'ont jamais été aussi grand
pour l'europe
est ce qu'on a vraiment une classe
politique au sein des vingt-sept ou des
28 qui soit à la hauteur de ces enjeux
je pense notamment au couple franco
allemand
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose de coincer
martin schulz aujourd'hui nous avons
vraiment un déficit de volonté d'agir
sur la base d'un compromis
encore une fois l'union européenne est
forte ou pas mais ça dépend des états
membres des gouvernements des états
membres si votre des questions la classe
politique concerne les chefs des
gouvernements des états de l'union
européenne donc ne sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux
quelques heures parmi eux
certainement pas et en ce qui concerne
le couple franco allemand
c'est vrai que sont les la coopération
franco allemand de l'union européenne un
problème mais soyons clairs le couple
franco-allemand seule ne suffit plus une
raison pourquoi j'ai trouvé très
raisonnable que matt et rennes c'est par
exemple est invité à bientôt ten de
joindre ce couple président du conseil
italien
alors en attendant pour revenir sur les
britanniques beaucoup vivent dans
d'autres pays d'europe et notamment en
france et s'empresse de demander leur
naturalisation
flora sauvage a été voir en dordogne a
aimé ou 10 % des habitants du village
sont des anglais reportage
tim richardson est viticulteur ce bris
thalys est installé dans le périgord il
ya 25 ans là il faut essayer de déguster
un petit peu les raisins pouvoir la
maturité des feux logotype le croquer
pour voir si ça va donner des goûts et
végétales pas au seuil et municipales
dans le petit village des mets team n'a
jamais été au bout des formalités pour
obtenir la nationalité française
même au lendemain du bric site j'ai déjà
commencé deux fois au moins
mais comme je suis pas très fan avec
papiers j'ai commencé à remplir le
dossier j'ai jamais fini je n'ai jamais
aller jusqu'au bout mais bon je ne
finirai pas le faire mais pour l'instant
c'est pas une obligation je me sens pas
obligé
je me sens plus européen que qu'autre
chose
et met au coeur du périgord cette cité
médiévale du xiiie siècle compte 2600
habitants 10% sont britanniques
au détour des petites ruelles se trouve
l'école franco britannique notre dame
ici un tiers des enfants sont
anglophones
ap ap clap your hands alors que des
monnaies c'est magnifique ce village en
l'assumant balader au au centre ville
vous avez les commerçants qui parlent
anglais
on croisera sur son volant à droite
c'est au travers de la manche pub salon
de thé et pâtisseries anglaises à la clé
et mes affiches et couleurs de l'union
jack
au café des arts la langue de
shakespeare a pris le dessus sur la
langue de molière retraités ce couple
vit en france depuis 9 ans déjà et il
n'envisage pas de repartir
même si le taux de la livre sterling a
chuté à 1 euro 16 depuis le bric site
est la plus grande inquiétude que j'ai
concerne le taux de change entre l'euro
et la livre sterling car avec la
dévaluation tous les mois ça évolue et
cela fait une grosse différence sur nos
stations de retraite
et ça ça m'inquiète carole est une
institutrice à la retraite elle s'est
installée en dordogne il ya un an
attiré par le climat et la douceur de
vivre mais elle n'est pas sûre de
pouvoir rester en france après le break
site
oui j'ai une maison à vendre en
angleterre il y avait plein d'acheteurs
potentiels mais quand le break site est
arrivé le marché immobilier s'est cassé
la figure mort donc été obligé de
baisser énormément le prix de la maison
vaste mais n'est toujours pas vendu et
la sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne a aussi un impact sur le
marché immobilier en france
comme l'expliquent la gérante de
l'agencé léonore des mais nous avons
effectivement une baisse de la
fréquentation des retraités sur le
marché immobilier en dordogne et c'est
un gros créneau est un gros marché
aujourd'hui qui est un marché quand même
important parce que c'était des achats
conséquents niveau financier assez haut
aujourd'hui la personne retraitée
anglaise van den appartement acheté une
maison dans la région et la mettais à
son goût
donc acheté déjà quelque chose de
conséquent et puis faisait refaire une
salle de bain du chauffage l'isolation
etc
comme on n'a pas cette cette clientèle
là les artisans ont le même problème
les artisans locaux qui par répercussion
voient leurs carnets de commandes se
vident et une menace sur l'emploi qui
planent aussi sur l'aéroport de bergerac
il dessert quotidiennement de nombreuses
villes outre manche cette infrastructure
représente 153 millions d'euros de
retombées économiques installés en
france depuis 24 ans doit jurek craint
l'impact du bric site sur l'activité
économique en dordogne à l'aéroport qui
cette année va arriver à des chiffres
assez incroyable de 300 mille pattes à
deux passagers dont 90% sont des
britanniques qui font ou l'aller où le
retour ou les deux si on n'arrivait pas
à avoir
contractuellement en une situation
claire entre la grande bretagne ici
l'aéroport de bergerac souffrirait mais
c'est pas seulement l'aéroport de
bergerac qui va souffrir c'est aussi de
tourisme c'est aussi l'économie en terme
général tourisme marché immobilier le
bric site a déjà des effets sur
l'économie locale en dordogne mais tim
richardson reste confiant en l'avenir
d'urate de toute façon des compromis
quelque part après les négociations qui
vont durer au moins deux ans encore le
roi des cons premier il y aura des
accords bilatéraux ppa terreau ses seins
donc on trouvera toujours une solution
comme steam 150000 britanniques vivent
en france
outre manche ce sont 300 milles
expatriés français
tous appellent de leurs voeux un accord
entre la grande bretagne et les autres
pays membres de l'union européenne
martin schulz quand on voit la situation
des britanniques aujourd'hui qui vivent
dans d'autres pays d'europe
comment assurer leurs droits est ce qu
il faut faire en sorte de leur faciliter
la tâche pour obtenir une double
nationalité
si ceux ci souhaitent rester européen
tout d'abord il reste européens même
s'ils sont sur l'île britannique mais
ils sortent de l'union européenne s'ils
veulent rester la grande nombre des
ressortissants du royaume uni qui ont
maintenant ce problème qu'ils sont dans
un temps prévisible citoyens d'un tiers
état
incroyable citoyens de la grande
bretagne et le ressortissant d'un tir
est un tir pays
incroyable je trouve il faut aider ces
gens qui vivent chez nous dans l'union
européenne qui travaillent souvent où on
travaille et passent leurs étrennes
maintenant dans l'union européenne il
faut leur aider donc ça veut dire que
vous seriez enclin à leur offrir en fait
des facilités pour obtenir des papiers
plus facilement en allemagne en france
au portugal en espagne
s'ils veulent moi je suis favorable à
trouver une solution surtout pour le
séjour pour la certitude en ce qui
concerne l'assurance des maladies le
retrait de ces terrasses dans le cadre
de la droit de résidence permanente donc
mais pour les aider si ça passe par la
nationalité ou par d'autres moyens hui
il faut aussi soulevé la question qu'est
ce qu'il y aura avec les citoyens de
l'union européenne en grande-bretagne
qui sont actuellement
rappellons nous les incidents qu'il y a
eu en grande bretagne contre les
polonais qui ont osé une situation
vraiment difficile alors plus largement
la hongrie a eu un référendum
il ya quelques jours qui assure la
politique migratoire européenne qui a
abouti en fait à un non clair et net
sauf qu'il a été invalidé par manque de
participation est ce que c'est une bonne
ou une mauvaise nouvelle finalement
cette invalidation
est-ce que viktor orban nom ressort
affaibli le gouvernement de l'hongrie a
essayé d' instrumentaliser la politique
des réfugiés pour une campagne à
l'intérieur du pays campagne de la
politique nationale et la large majorité
des citoyens hongrois n'ont pas se
laisser instrumentaliser
il y avait un participation finalement
avec des votes valides de 39 9% soit
dire la large majorité des hongrois a
aussi voté avec leur abstention et
donner un signal qu'on ne peut pas
instrumentaliser à tout un peuple pour
un projet d'un parti je crois que victor
obinna part il n'a pas acquis la
majorité pour une stratégie qui était
visiblement qui avait comme l'objectif
visiblement la politique intérieure en
utilisant un projet européen maintenant
néanmoins il faut interpréter que 95% de
ceux qui ont participé ont voté non à
dire c'est quand même un chiffre
considérable pas la majorité large
majorité n'a pas participé et exprimer
son opinion par l'abstention mais ceux
qui ont voté ont voté non et maintenant
je reviens à une réponse qui vous est
donné au début de notre entretien
on peut toujours se radicaliser un peu
plus d'un côté comme de l'autre - je
suis absolument pour qu'on applique les
règles de l'union européenne c'est la
délocalisation des sceaux soixante mille
réfugiés nous avons décidé l'année
dernière voit rarement
c'était l'objectif de
le référendum de déclarer cette décision
dans le cadre de la législation
européenne
absolument correctement adopté avec un
vote majoritaire où l'on grille était
dans la minorité de déclarer ça comme
illégal illégitime s'est échoué
on peut maintenant dire bon et
maintenant on commence avec l'arrêt de
localisation mais vous comme moi nous
savons depuis un an nous avons parmi ces
sources 60000 distribués parmi les vingt
huit états membres autour des 5000 se
dire en conséquence on peut en exister
mais il faut aussi prendre note que ça
ne fonctionne pas donc enfin israël et
puis l'on attendait et les autres ils
peuvent naturellement a insisté sur leur
ligne
on prend personne je crois c'est au
détriment le prix pour ça et payés par
les réfugiés alors le secrétaire général
de l'onu est venue cette semaine pour
ratifier au nom de l'union européenne
l'accord de paris après la coop 21
ségolène royal était également présente
la ratification ne signifie pas pour
autant traité contraignant
martin schulze est ce qu'on peut espérer
que cet accord de paris soit à un moment
ou à un autre suivies d'effet
contrairement à tous les accords qui ont
pu être signés auparavant suis optimiste
le handi protocole de kyoto ceux
d'irlande et traités précédents sur le
changement climatique entre l'adoption
et la mise en vigueur on a eu huit ans
maintenant nous sommes un nom après la
conférence
pennant après la conférence de paris et
nous ratifions déjà ici au parlement
européen contraignant pour l'union
européenne et arrivant le chiffre
nécessaire des états membres des nations
unies pour les mettre en vigueur
mondialement est applicable pour ces
états qui ont déjà ratifié
ça veut dire ça marche maintenant
beaucoup plus vite qu'eux
à l'époque je sors c'est quand même bon
signe on a souvent dit de l'europe
qu'elle était à la traîne sur ce
protocole il a fallu que ce soit la
chine et les états unis qui ratifie
début septembre pour que derrière il y
ait une forme l'inde il ya encore
quelques jours
que diriez vous de la position de ces
états européens merci pour votre
question parce que sa mère aurore la
possibilité d'encore une fois de parler
l'europe qui est l'europe et un tel
gouvernement que nous rendons nos pieds
l'europe qui est l'europe vous avez posé
cette question on dit souvent l'europe
traîne qui est l'europe
je vais vous donner un exemple moi je
suis un député allemand l'allemagne est
la troisième force industrielle du monde
l'allemagne a abandonné jusqu'à 2022 au
plus tard de l'énergie nucléaire au
japon
en même temps l'allemagne est en train
de baisser sa consommation de charbon à
40%
nous sommes en train de boire je suis
député d'une région avec des mines de
charbon qui seront pelouse en même temps
ou l'allemagne sorte de l'énergie
nucléaire et baisse le charbon
l'augmentation de la consommation de
l'énergie est en pleine augmentation
croissance pourquoi parce que le succès
industriel de l'allemagne
l'allemagne va montrer jusqu'à 2022
qu'un états industrialisés comme
l'allemagne troisième force industrielle
du monde peut sortir de l'énergie
nucléaire
réduire considérablement la consommation
de charbon et remplir sa part des
énergies renouvelables
c'est à mes yeux sortent comme tout
demoun project qui traînent l'europe qui
est l'europe l'allemagne pas j'en suis
sûr même la france veut baisser
l'énergie nucléaire alors encore une
fois l'union européenne est forte comme
les états membres de l'union de le
permettent
ségolène royal donc ministre de
l'environnement en france et président
de la cap 21 et est ici pour ratifier
donc cet accord de paris au nom de
l'union européenne avec ban ki moon
certains ici l'ont accusé de mépriser la
commission d' enquête sur le diesel
gates qui est ici au sein de ce
parlement parce qu'elle a refusé d'y
participer est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec les députés qui ont interpellé
ségolène royal je sais qu'il y a ceux de
controversé entre la commission denquête
et pas seulement ségolène royal le
gouvernement de la france il ya quelques
des gouvernements des états membres qui
pose des questions s'il est admissible
pour une telle commission denquête de
les écouter sur des sujets qu'ils
trouvent pas dans lé cadre du mandat de
cette commission denquête moi je vais
m'en parler de dossiers
je crois en gouvernement est toujours
bien conseillé de passer devant la
commission soit du parlement national ou
du parlement européen connie hedegaard
ancienne commissaire au climat qui a
rejoint volkswagen
justement on a appris il ya quelques
jours après rose et manuel barosso chez
goldman sachs on élit crosse à la tête
d'une entreprise basée aux bahamas est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un problème
d'exemplarité martin schulz au sein de
l'ancienne commission européenne est en
général au sein de au sein de l'union
européenne et ses dirigeants
est ce qu'en fait ces anciens
commissaires ne sont ils pas les
meilleurs agents de propagande anti eux
songent au club oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait
contre ça les règles ça passe dans les
règles actuelles et ça montre qu'il faut
changer les règles actuelles elles ne
sont pas assez elles sont plutôt trop
permissif pour nous je crois le
ce que nous appelons ici la couleur
comme dans deux conduits n'a jamais pris
en considération un tel comportement
parce que à mes yeux c'était pas
imaginable que le président de la
commission sortons il y a maintenant
deux ans il est sorti dans une situation
comme la situation actuelle se laisse
embauché par goldman sachs pour les
conseiller pour le break site
alors ça on ne peut pas inscrire dans un
règlement parce que moi j'avoue
questions éthiques
j'ai pas m'imaginer que c'était possible
donc il faut changer ses règles on a
besoin des temps de transition
il faut aussi trouver des moyens si on
interdit à une commission
hahn commissaire une commissaire qui
sortent du la commission ne pas prendre
travail liée à la travail précédente
pendant impériaux 10 ans de 10 ans il
faut quand même les rémunérer on ne peut
pas leur demander tu n'as pas le droit
de travailler
tu n'es plus commissaire maintenant on
va te payer la location sociale
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça donc on a
besoin des règles transitoires mais dans
ces règles transitoires il faut de toute
façon éviter qu'il prenne une position
pour exploiter leurs connaissances de
leurs postes exécutifs précédentes ça ne
fonctionne pas du tout comme ça j'ai
parlé avec jean claude juncker au dessus
et nous sommes absolument d'accord qu'il
faut améliorer les règles alors vous
arriver au bout de votre second mandat
ici au parlement européen cinq ans
consécutifs ce qui n'était jamais arrivé
quasiment histoire du parlement est ce
que vous allez briguer un troisième
mandat martin schulz à la tête de cette
institution
j'ai bien entendu votre question j'ai
aussi préparé une réponse mais doute la
longue liste des questions qui vous
venez soulevé montre que je suis occupé
du matin jusqu'au soir de trouver des
solutions concrètes sur mon avenir je
vais réfléchir après effectivement vous
êtes très occupé ici au sein de ce
parlement mais on le saura j'imagine
dans quelques dans quelques semaines
s'il ya des collègues qui disent il fait
sur ordre travaille pas mal c'est quand
même pas je prends goût sympa comme une
insulte
donc je veux te voir comme un
encouragement en fait à continuer votre
votre votre travail ici au sein de cette
institution et ses excellentes mais on
veut merci vous classez vous voilà c'est
la fin de cette émission mais pas de
panique vous pouvez la revoir en replay
et à l'envi sur nos sites
lcp point fr et publicsenat.fr la
semaine prochaine vous retrouverez amat
à dire depuis bruxelles
très belle semaine à tous ciao